So Hank a couple days ago
I had a fairly important phone call like
important enough that I can't tell you
specifically who I was talking to and I was pretty nervous about it because I always get nervous about phone calls.
But it was going pretty well, and then when it came time for the phone call to end. They were like: "Alright!
Well take care! Talk to you soon!" And I said: "Best wishes!"
Best wishes?
You know they hung up the phone and they said: "Did that guy just say goodbye to us by saying 'best wishes?'"
So just a memo to all the teenage nerdfighters out there who are wondering will my self-consciousness ever go away: Yeah,
no, it won't. Best wishes. Hank, as you'll no doubt notice, puff levels
have gone down considerably. When I went to the barber
I said, "Can you just take a little bit off the top?
I like it to be pretty long and messy." And she said, "Sure thing."
I took off my glasses like I always do when I get a haircut. 20 minutes later
I put my glasses back on and I was bald. And she said (and I'm quoting her directly here), "Is that short enough?"
No, actually could you make it a little bit shorter because when I said just a little bit off the top
I like it long and messy what I meant was: I'm joining the marines. So Hank, as you know,
I was gonna try to do a question Tuesday
video today where I attempt to break the world record for "number of questions answered in four minutes."
But unfortunately it's going to have to wait until next Tuesday because I haven't even finished going through all of the questions.
Because there were more than 2,000 questions. So question Tuesday will be next Tuesday. In the meantime
let's do some housekeeping. Housekeeping item number one: if you live in or near Spartanburg, South Carolina, you should come see me
speak about my books and sign them on Friday? Saturday? Saturday! This Saturday
I'll be signing in the morning in the afternoon and speaking at two o'clock at the Spartanburg Public library Jambo Read.
Jambo Read is a nice pun.
It's like all the fun of a party but with books. Housekeeping item number two: if you live in or near Depew,
New York - and I know a lot of nerdfighters do - then please attend the meeting on Tuesday, March 4th
when they're going to talk about whether to keep my book "Looking for Alaska" in the curriculum at Depew High School.
You can find out more in the video info. Housekeeping item number three: the nerdfighter blurbing book club. Hank,
this is off topic, but I really like saying blurbing. Blurbing is one of those words that when you say it,
it sounds like your voice is turning into a robot voice.  [in a robot voice] Blurbing. Blurbing. Blurbing. Blurbing.
Blurbing. Blurbing. Anyway nerdfighters, if you want to participate in the blurbing and potentially win fantastic prizes
you need to write a blurb about Maureen Johnson's book "13 Little Blue Envelopes" of
10 words or less and post it as a blog post in your profile at the Ning.
We'll read them all, I promise. The deadline is Sunday at midnight. Then we're going to go to bed promptly at 12:01,
get some sleep, wake up the next morning, and start the next book in the nerdfighter Blurbing book club: "Slaughterhouse-five" by Kurt Vonnegut
which I'm picking because it's really good, and I haven't read it for a long time. Plus
it's published all over the world so international nerdfighters can participate, too. And finally housekeeping item number four: Hank
it's no secret that I really love two things. The first is nerdfighter babies
and the second is when a nerdfighter finds another nerdfighter
and they fall in nerdfighter-like. I like nerdfighter-like so much partly because it makes me feel
like, you know if it wasn't for us then there might be less like in the world.
Which is a really good feeling and a nice counterbalance to having people say, "I don't want to listen to this freak.
I want to see giraffes doing it." Hank, there's been quite a lot of nerdfighter-like going around lately
thanks partly to the Ning which allows, you know,
nerdfighters to meet other nerdfighters and look at their interests and read their blog posts
and see their pictures and everything.
But the particular reason I'm mentioning it is that the vloglovers YouTube channel is back.
Noted secret siblings Abbey Songs From a Hat and Todd Toddly are a nerdfighter-like. Yay!
That's right, Hank. They're touching and
hugging and
nothing else. Hank, speaking of Nuclear chain reactions of awesome,
I hope I see some nerdfighters in Spartanburg, South Carolina on Saturday, and I'll see you later this week
singing - I'm very excited, but I'm not going to tell them what you're singing about. Hank, I think there's only one thing left to say:
Best wishes!